what is the best sort of life for a
human being
Socrates claimed in 400 BC that a man
lives a happier life if he's just
even if he's thrown starving into prison
for the rest of his life then if he's
unjust and he's celebrated and honored
all of his days and is never caught for
his crimes could that possibly be
correct if not why not and what
difference should the question make to
us now what moves the human heart
Shakespeare's characters throw us into
the depths of lust Envy greed pride
ambition one of those characters have to
say about the way that we act or that we
behave or that we believe and if so what
difference would it make to read about
them in Shakespeare and why Shakespeare
who is Elizabethan English is very
difficult for us who speak modern
English to understand Thomas Hobbes
wrote in 1651 a book called Leviathan
one of the two or three most influential
works in the history of thinking about
government and politics in Western
society he was writing from the midst of
a raging Civil War and he argued that
unless we gave all the power unless we
surrendered all ultimate control to a
legitimate king that we would all rob
and kill each other was he right about
that is that the way things actually
work and is the question relevant to us
today when we no longer believe in Kings
hello my name is Geoff Brendel and I'm
the Dean of undergraduate admissions at
Yale University
sure from time to time in the philosophy
department at Yale and my work in
philosophy centers around ethics and
also the history of the ideas that we've
had about something we like to call
human nature speaking of human nature
one of my personal heroes Aristotle
claimed that by Nature everyone seeks to
know everyone desires to know for the
purposes of this talk I'm going to
assume that you are already an
intellectually curious person and that
you're not only chasing after knowledge
as hard as you can you're also trying to
build up the skill sets and acquire the
kind of capacities and abilities that
you're going to need to become a better
learner overall if these things are in
fact true about you then here is my
advice in a nutshell
make a choice in college to read some
old books even a substantial number of
old books my argument will be that
reading the right old books in the right
way is better than reading only new
books much less using only new ways of
learning that have nothing to do with
books at all but let's be careful about
what I'm claiming and what I'm not
claiming I'm not claiming that you
should read only old books or that old
books are better because they're old or
that you should never read any new books
or that new books are worthless only
that you should read and learn how to
read some old books but which ones would
those be how do you learn how to read
them in the right way why should you
read them in college and how could doing
that change your life for the better how
is that going to make you smarter and
moreover how's it going to make you
wiser the dialogues of Socrates
Aristotle's ethics Oedipus wrecked
the City of God Leviathan Dante's
Inferno
King Lear Paradise Lost Warren peace
there are a lot of these books but why
spend a significant amount of your time
on books that by definition are outdated
why not go after the books that bring
everything up to date don't we know
everything those people already knew and
much much more so a little personal
background here I went off to university
in 1971 no one in my family had ever
graduated from college much less a place
like Yale I'd never visited across the
state line I never even had even been on
an airplane before the one that swept me
off to to New Haven Connecticut now when
I actually showed up at Yale I applied
in total ignorance and almost by
accident to a special freshman year
program called directed studies so what
is directed studies and directed studies
you take three full year courses in the
history of Western thought and
philosophy in literature and in politics
you start with what the classic Greeks
had to say and then you roll forward
with the centuries until you end up
about a century behind where we are
right now there is no textbooks there's
no summaries
there's no cliff notes you read only the
original works and it was both the
single most difficult and the single
most transforming educational experience
that I've ever had about fifteen years
ago
I came back to Yale after founding
companies managing organizations and
after earning a PhD in philosophy and
I'm having the opportunity there today
to teach in this very same program that
I took over 30 years ago so I've gotten
to know these classic works fairly well
I've become familiar with them I've seen
there
excellent students and I've had the
chance to stack them up against my own
life experience and stuff that I've read
from lots of modern books so here I am
ready to give you some good reasons to
look into the classics yourself now the
first thing to point out is something
that I think you already know there are
a lot of books out there and you don't
have much time the Library of Congress
has over 20 million volumes that's the
largest library in the world that's not
counting the journals the publication's
it's not counting the internet it's not
counting the blogs it's not counting
what Wikipedia is not counting the
entire Googleplex meanwhile down here on
the personal level I'm 58 years old I've
been a pretty strong reader for about 40
years back home I've got a personal
library of about 2,000 books volumes and
if you do the math that's about 50 books
times 40 years about 50 books a year
it's about a book a week I hope you can
see the problem my problem which is also
your problem which is we ain't going to
make it through the Library of Congress
not only that we're not going to get to
99.999% of everything that's ever been
written
you know Mahatma Gandhi said live as
though you'll die tomorrow but learn as
though you'll live forever
Gandhi was as aware as you and I are
that we're not going to live forever and
of course that means that you are going
to have to be extremely picky about what
you choose to read even if you live
according to Gandhi you literally have
no other choice but now it seems I've
only made my job harder because I've got
to persuade you that with this precious
time that you have for learning and
study which is dwindling all the time
that you're going to take some of
and devote it to things that are
outdated so let's focus on the principle
of necessity and that means the
principle of having to make these
difficult and time-consuming choices
I'd like to give you five reasons five
rough-and-ready criteria for identifying
a classic of literature or philosophy or
politics now know one or two of these
criteria are going to be decisive but I
think if you put them all together
they're going to prove actually to be
quite useful first the work addresses a
permanent universal concern about the
human condition from the philosophical
perspective it has something to say
about the way we should live from a
literary perspective it helps us imagine
different ways that we could live and
from a political perspective or an
historical perspective it helps us
remember ways that we have lived so
that's mark number one of a classic mark
number two is that the work has been a
game changer
it changed perspective or shifted
perspective on those issues both for the
earliest people who read the book and
also for those who came later mark
number three is that the work has
stimulated or provoked or responded to
many other important works mark number
four is that many generations of the
very best readers and the most expert
critics have rated the work highly as
one of the best and most important of
its kind even if those reviewers those
experts didn't agree on anything else
and even if they took or had a violent
argument with the work itself mark
number five is that the work usually
does require a strenuous effort to both
engage it and understand it but rewards
that great effort in multiple ways and
very highly
before we think about what these
criteria rule in let's think about what
they rule out let's say that you run up
to me with a novel that you picked up
just last week you wave it in the air
and you say professor Brendel I've got a
great book here for you it's an instant
classic even better than Moby Dick maybe
even better than Moby Dick
what am I likely to respond well it may
be in fact very good and your
recommendation may persuade me to read
it particularly if I have a high opinion
of you as an expert reader your new
favorite book may in fact become a
classic someday but it hasn't changed
the game as yet for other writers and
readers
it hasn't provoked or influenced lots of
other works how could it you don't know
how experts and other readers are going
to evaluate it over time you're not even
sure how you're going to see the book
over time but let's remember the
critical problem that we all have way
too many books and not nearly enough
time so where are you likely to get the
biggest bang for your reading dollar and
for your reading our something published
last week or something that stood the
centuries of tests by tough readers and
that has in fact spawned a great deal of
what you'll be reading today so I'm sort
of defining a classic as an old book
it's been through generations of readers
big game-changing ideas and something
that you can expect to find to be a
considerable challenge to tackle so
let's flush it out with just a few
examples before we talk about what good
it's going to do you to read such a book
in a college course
Socrates was a philosopher who lived in
Athens ancient Greece about 400 years
before the birth of Christ
you've probably heard his name even if
you know nothing else about him you may
also know that the other citizens of
Athens put him to death because he went
around asking a lot of challenging
questions needling people irritating
them with questions about their actions
and their beliefs that they didn't care
to answer well it's a remarkable fact
that for the past twenty four centuries
very few thinkers in the Western
tradition have been able to avoid having
to come at some point to grips with
Socrates in his life and his death it's
even more interesting that Socrates so
far as we know never actually wrote down
a single word he strolled around the
town embarrassing prominent people with
his questions he'd like to say that the
only superiority that he ever claimed
was that he was absolutely certain that
he was ignorant but he found that people
believed that they knew all kinds of
things and in that he was superior to
them now one of the young aristocrats
who got a big charge out of following
Socrates around the town was a young
wrestler named Plato maybe the first
scholar athlete so Plato wrote a series
of dialogues after Socrates died that
featured his hero in the principal role
the early dialogues do seem to reflect
for us this business of walking around
asking these difficult questions that no
one can answer later in the later
dialogues Plato begins to use Socrates
as a mouthpiece or as someone who
represents the kinds of new questions
that Plato himself began to ask under
Socrates inspiration to get me some
indication of how expert readers over
time have understood Plato's thought and
its central importance in the tradition
the great 20th century philosopher and
petition Alfred North Whitehead once
said that all of Western thought is
nothing more than a series of footnotes
to Plato quite a claim and remember that
it was Plato's encounter with Socrates
that inspired all of Plato's thought now
Plato's single most important dialogue
with Socrates as the hero is a dialogue
called the Republic and in it Plato
tries to formulate two basic fundamental
and universal questions what's the best
sort of life for a human being and
beyond that what's the best Society for
producing the conditions under which
human beings could live that kind of
life these two questions give the book
the first mark of greatness that I was
that I was discussing which is the
Republic addresses permanent and
universal questions ones that might
puzzle you as much as they did Socrates
and Plato
the book opens with a really terrific
argument about justice whether it's the
just or the unjust person who gets the
better of it in life Socrates confronts
a very sarcastic and very aggressive
young man named tres amigas who attacks
the common notion that justice is a
virtue listen then says through Simic
Asst I proclaim that might is right and
that justice as you call it is whatever
happens to be in the interest of the
stronger there are different forms of
government but they all make laws
according to their own interests
everywhere there is only one principle
of so-called justice which is that
justice turns out to be whatever happens
to be in the interest of the stronger so
have you ever heard someone make this
argument before that might makes right
the justice has no fixed meaning that
what is considered just in a society is
just whatever the people running the
society
say it is I'd be surprised if you hadn't
because it's a universally recurring
argument not only throughout the dorms
of any good colleges down through time
but also down through the centuries in
the debates of the very best
philosophers now I can't do justice in
this short talk to even this relatively
simple opening framing argument of the
Republic between through symmachus and
Socrates but essentially Socrates tries
to answer through Simic Asst by pointing
out that we distinguish between good
rulers and bad rulers just like we
distinguish between good Shepherds and
bad Shepherds or good boat captains and
bad boat captains the good Shepherds act
in the best interests of the sheep and
the good boat captains act in the best
interests of their boats and passengers
so a ruler if he's rightly named a ruler
or she's rightly named a ruler is
someone who acts in the best interest of
the subjects and the bad ones don't
throw Symmachus calls this drivel he
points out that the Shepherd hardly
cares for the Sheep he's simply
fattening them for the slaughter
consider further most foolish Socrates
he says that the just is always a loser
in comparison with the unjust
first of all in private matters wherever
the unjust is the partner of the just
you will find that the unjust man always
gains more and the just man always gets
less next in their dealings with the
government when there is an income tax
the just man will pay more and the
unjust man less on the same amount of
income and when there is anything to be
received the one gains nothing the other
gains much by this standard for semuc us
goes on to say the best life is actually
the one to be had by the absolute tyrant
who can take anything that he wishes by
force and make everyone else pay honor
and obedience
so not only is being a tyrant the best
kind of life all people would become
tyrants if only they could now Socrates
at this point
knocks through Semak is down with some
verbal and logical tricks but I'm not
going to take you through in this talk
and outwitted through semi cos stalks
off from the conversation not to return
the young friends of Socrates are not
satisfied with this outcome and they
take up the core question but in a much
harder form they ask Socrates to prove
to them that the just person is always
happier and always has a better life
than the unjust person no matter how
poor deprived disgraced or reviled the
just man might be and no matter how
wealthy honored and completely unharmed
an unjust man might be so the rest of
the Republic is Plato's attempt to
answer this question along with a number
of other questions in the course of it
he draws a surprisingly compelling
picture of human psychology he
speculates on the nature of knowledge he
presents a proposal for the ideal state
and he polishes it all off with a theory
about enlightenment and about the
ultimate nature of reality along the way
he speculates about the relations
between men and women how to raise and
educate children to be good citizens and
the right way for human beings to
investigate questions of all kinds now
Plato himself had a brilliant student
named Aristotle who for my money
actually surpassed Plato in a number of
different ways but was certainly heavily
influenced by Plato so let me just give
you a very quick notion of how things
play out in the history of thought for
Plato's and Aristotle's thinking and in
fact for your own
first they're thinking stays very much
alive in Greece in Rome for 400 years
until the coming of Christ and beyond
that for many centuries more if you
happen to be a Christian what you think
of is Christianity the very concepts and
ideas that form the basis for
Christianity actually turn out to Oh a
great deal to Plato and Aristotle
virtually everything that Christianity
teaches about God about human nature
about human fulfillment arises from what
the historians of religion like to call
the marriage of Jerusalem and Athens
that is the marriage of Greek and Jewish
thinking one big moment for this process
comes about eight centuries after Plato
and Aristotle four centuries after
Christ
when a man named st. Augustine writes a
truly monumental work in the history of
Western thought a real classic the City
of God he writes this book just as the
Roman Empire is collapsing around his
ears from invasions of barbarians
Augustine was very influenced by
platonic thinking even though he wasn't
all that familiar directly with Plato's
works and he sets the course of
Christian thinking for a very long time
in fact if you're knowledgeable about
the history of Christian doctrine or
Christian theology you'll know that
Augustine is influential right up to the
current moment then another 800 years
after San Agustin a priest around the
Year 1250 named Thomas Aquinas
rediscovers many of the lost works of
Aristotle to put this very briefly he
puts together the thought of Aristotle
with the thought of Augustine comes up
with a new synthesis for Christian
thinking and it turns out to be a
game-changer the result is for the most
part what the Roman Catholic Church
teaches to this very day st. Thomas
Aquinas is the primary orthodox
theologian of Catholicism meanwhile the
Italian poet Dante who lives one
generation after Aquinas reads Aquinas
is influenced by his work and as one of
the three or four greatest poets ever to
live presents us with his own view of
human nature fulfillment and human
destiny when he writes his three epic
poems about Hell purgatory in heaven
you've probably heard of Dante's Inferno
so now fast-forward another 250 years
and we come to about the year 1500
Martin Luther in Germany now Luther gets
very angry about a lot of things that
are happening in the Catholic Church he
goes back and rips Aquinas apart he
trashes Aristotle and he returns for his
inspiration to the game-changing works
of st. Augustine and st. Paul by doing
this Luther also starts a process that
splinters Christianity into a million
pieces
game changers
another hundred or so years after Luther
we have John Milton Milton is an English
poet he takes his inspiration from the
reforming of Christianity the Protestant
Reformation and he writes the greatest
epic poem in the English language
Paradise Lost
it gives his own picture of the
Protestant picture of human nature human
history human destiny God's will so if
you happen to be a Catholic and you
believe that the Catholic Church teaches
the same thing always in everywhere and
has from the very beginning or if you're
an Evangelical Protestant and you
believe that all of your own views come
directly from a plain straightforward
reading of New Testament texts in either
case you could not be more mistaken the
very teachings of the Catholic Church or
the very ways that a Protestant
Christian interprets the words of the
Bible in Scripture results from
speculations and collisions taking place
among ideas that involve Plato Aristotle
Augustine Aquinas st. Paul Dante Martin
Luther and Milton here's a very small
example of something quite specific many
Christians believe that Satan the devil
was once a great Archangel in fact that
he was the highest of all the angels and
that his name was Lucifer and that he
rebelled against God in heaven before
the creation of the entire world
later he successfully tempted our first
parents and Adam and Eve to eat an apple
in the Garden of Eden
there is actually remarkably little in
the Hebrew Scriptures about Satan and
what's there does not happen to include
these beliefs Satan as we imagine him is
actually a much later invention and he's
not thought of as either a fallen angel
or even fully identified with the
serpent in the garden who tempt Adam and
Eve to taste the fruit until four
century
after the life of Christ Augustine has a
lot to do with who Satan becomes and the
picture that you yourself may have in
your mind of a rebel angel a war in
heaven between the good angels and the
bad angels well that's something that
John Milton imagined for us when he
published Paradise Lost in 1667 Socrates
and Plato and Aristotle exert influences
in many other threads or conversations
or discussions that are taking place in
the Western history of ideas for
instance the encounter with Socrates
enters very strongly into soaring
Kierkegaard's work in the 19th century
Kierkegaard's the Godfather of
existentialism ultimately Kierkegaard
produces all these other philosophers
like Heidegger and Sartre Socrates also
provoked and gave shape in an encounter
a philosophical encounter gave shape to
Friedrich Nietzsche's thought also in
the 19th century as Nietzsche actually
seeks to try to undo what he considers
to be the disaster that Socrates has
bequeathed to Western civilization so
you simply cannot study the history of
Western thought without running into
Plato and Socrates just around about
every corner you can't read a thinker
who hasn't been influenced himself or
herself by these ideas in some way as
well as the way that they actually posed
the original questions what's the best
sort of life for a human being and
what's the best kind of society in which
that sort of life can be lived
so the Republic is still what I would
call a living book it still fuels
encounters it still provokes us provokes
students in my classroom I think just as
much as Socrates provoke them in the
streets of ancient Greece it has
something to teach us
something to connect us very deeply to
the ideas of many others it's something
that's made our society in some very
deep respects what it is you might say
that Plato and his inspiration Socrates
are the opposite of outdated thinkers on
this rather quick - through the
centuries I've not forgotten the
question that I'm supposed to answer
which is so what why does it do you any
good to know these things what's all
this about strenuous effort and what's
that got to do with something being a
classic aren't there any classics that
are easy to read or to cut to the chase
and regarding all the strenuous effort
why do I really have to dig in to
Plato's Republic at all why can't I just
hear about it from you or why can't I
read the Cliff Notes version or why
can't I find a summary or a digest or
look on my neighbors notes
why won't Wikipedia tell me everything
that is truly important for me to take
away from the book why can't I take the
take advantage of the fact that all
these other people have read it
commented on it and used it for some
purpose or another what's the takeaway
well the 20th century philosopher and
critic Mortimer Adler put it this way
the path of true learning is strewn with
rocks not roses but I am still saying he
goes on that the great books can be read
by every person in one sense of course
they are the most difficult to read but
they are in another sense the most
readable both for the less and the more
competent reader because they are the
most instructive what Adler is is trying
to tell us here is that just because
something is difficult doesn't mean that
the time you spend with it is not
worthwhile and
fact that any amount of time that you
spend with one of these kinds of works
will actually be more valuable to you
than the same amount of time that you
spend on a work of lesser quality but
what Adler wants us to understand is the
principle of no pain no gain and in fact
that in the case of works of the mind
that whatever the pain you experience
whatever time and study that you're
going to give to these works
these works pay a greater return you
might say they have a higher interest
rate than the ordinary stocks and bonds
that you're going to be exposed to in
the rest of your courses so what I'm
going to do now is to try to give you
five takeaways that is five valuable
things that are specific to you that you
can pull out of these books and take
away with you to the other things that
you're studying and also to your own
life number one the value of forgotten
ideas some old ideas are not actually
outdated the entire period that we call
the European Renaissance actually
consisted of people rediscovering a
bunch of ideas from the ancient world
and giving them a new application so
point number one is some of these old
ideas are actually valuable number two
the value of making connections between
ideas there is less new Under the Sun
than what you might think and seeing the
connections that tie one thinker to
another in a tradition also gives you a
measure of how far we've come on some
problems and what problems seem to have
heavily resisted the attempts of human
beings to give them answers
the one that we've been considering from
time to time through the course of this
talk is one of those what's the best
sort of life for a human being this is a
question that you'll be asking yourself
as you try to figure out things like
where am I going to get a job where am I
going to live
I going to marry how am I going to raise
my children these are questions that are
permanent aspects of the human condition
you're also going to discover that this
is not the kind of question in which
science has suddenly delivered a
fantastic new answer people have been
asking and answering this question for a
long time and looking at some old
thinkers can see you can help you see
the connections between the ways people
originally ask these questions in the
way we do but also give you a
perspective on what's been solved which
in some of these cases is very little
and what remains for you to consider and
actually determine by the way that you
live your own life the third thing is
that great books of the past are going
to engage you with a number of great
minds who don't share any of your
assumptions just as we were talking
about with Plato it's a different
culture a different morality a different
religion a different politics call this
the value of strangeness which is not
only an additional perspective on what
you believe but I'm going to claim is
also a primary source of human
creativity the fourth value is quite
frankly the value of building up your
intellectual muscle power you don't get
to be a better wrestler by wrestling all
the little kids in your neighborhood and
beating them up and signing them on
crying if you're going to be a better
wrestler you're going to have to get
your own nose bloody by going up against
people who are bigger and stronger and
better than you are
so finally 5 there is the value of
forming better judgements
once you've encountered with the best of
all time and wrestled them to the ground
you're going to be much better
positioned to make your own good
discerning judgments about where to
spend your precious time without having
past generations of experts to do the
reading you might say ahead of you and
post the signs without knowing how a
book is going to influence other books
and without yourself being able to
figure what the what the views are going
to be of this book in the future you
will be able to tell junk from gold
trash from something that's worthwhile
why because you'll know when you're
actually up against a real mind you will
have experienced the best that we know
so let's take down a little bit into the
value of some old and outdated ideas a
man named Malthus in 1798 published a
classic work and political economy it's
called an essay in the principle of
population now the basic idea is that
populations can only grow up to the
point where they necessarily collapse
because of limited resources famine and
disease but the essay explores the ideas
and a lot of very interesting ways and
actually it was a major influence on
Charles Darwin and the development of
the theory of evolution
despite the game-changing nature of this
work economists and scientists of the
Industrial Age have generally held that
Malthus was wrong why because he
predicted we were all going to die
back in the 18th century he thought that
we were going to outrun the food sources
with our population and that nothing
could stop a headlong rush over the
cliff what he did not take into proper
account were the game-changing aspects
of human ingenuity and creativity that
would find a way around resource
bottlenecks now during the oil shocks of
the 1970s and if you go back and look
for this you'll see that the ideas of
Malthus came very much back into view
why because people were seeing resources
begin to run out the world's population
had doubled over a period of about 30 to
60 years and it was going to be set to
double again so Thomas Malthus and his
ideas about what happens when you
increase the population past the
carrying load came around for more
currency today if you google them
Malthus you're going to get over three
million hits on the Internet
his fundamental ideas are once again at
the center of debates about peak oil
environmental damage global population
the prospects for global catastrophe
Malthusian ideas are everywhere and his
work is being invoked as people wonder
if the world is about to prove Malthus
right in the end here's another example
of old ideas being mined for new
insights in ancient Greece Aristotle
wrote a book called in the comic a in
ethics or for short
the ethics it's actually a book about
human happiness and about what it takes
to be a happy person now we don't
ordinarily associate the idea of ethics
with a work on happiness we think about
ethics as being things like moral
obligations duties what were what were
called upon to perform despite our
desires to do other things
Aristotle had a different perspective on
this he was an original proponent of the
idea and you may have heard this idea
that virtue is its own reward that in
fact the things that make you an
excellent parent the things that make
you an excellent citizen are also the
things if pursued consciously and done
well make you a happy human being in
other words that there's a dedication to
excellence where excellence consists of
the virtues that are required for us to
live well and do well with one another
that is the foundation for human beings
to be happy this goes these days by the
name virtue ethics and philosophers and
psychologists all over the world are
studying what makes for human happiness
Aristotle actually has something
extremely contemporary to contribute to
that debate so again reading these works
gives you a very
current sense of what progress consists
of in one whole area of human thought
and what even our notion of progress
might mean when we start to talk about
something like human happiness are there
really new messages coming from the from
the cosmos about what it takes to be
happy my third value or takeaway
involved what I call the value of
strangeness now this one's a little
harder to explain so let me use an
analogy you've probably traveled people
like to travel some people travel a
great deal what do people feel like they
learn from traveling particularly travel
to another society one of the things
that good travelers people who have done
this well and spent enough time in a
foreign society to really learn
something about it they generally say
that they're struck by the ways that
that society is different from our own
and they're struck by the different
kinds of answers that people give to
questions that we suddenly discover
we've made a lot of assumptions about
that is we made an assumption about our
lifestyle or an assumption about what
people want out of life or an assumption
about how people are going to get those
things that actually isn't operating in
this other society at all and of course
it might make a stop and think is our
way of doing this actually the best way
of doing it might I pick up some ideas
from this other place
well great books can have some of this
same effect through the value of
strangeness let's consider two women
writers for a moment and if you've been
paying attention you might have noticed
that I haven't talked about any women
thinkers or writers up to this point and
in that regard it's important to
remember that until very recent times
very few women had access to the kinds
of education or we're given the kind of
encouragement to engage in this kind of
thinking or this kind of work or this
kind of reading as they are too
a so you might say it's only very
recently that women have entered this
long conversation why because they were
excluded from it
Jane Austen was a brilliant novelist and
what Jane Austen wrote about were the
manners and the ways of life and the
marriage and family arrangements of
English country gentry of the late 1700s
now it's very unlikely that you're going
to have much knowledge about the ways of
life that were current among the English
gentry in the late 1700s and that is
just what makes encountering them
valuable and what makes encountering
Jane Austen herself valuable for she
knows this world and these people inside
and out and she's an exceptional clever
and devastating observer of the human
heart you come to know both the world
that these people occupied and the ways
in which they occupied this world in a
way that no other author is ever going
to reveal or take another example Emily
Dickinson
now Emily Dickinson was one of the two
or three master poets that the United
States has produced she had an even more
narrow and an even stranger world to
show us consisting primarily of the
workings of her own mind and her
emotions which were exceptionally
focused and intense it was Dickenson a
virtual recluse who said partying is all
we know of heaven and is all we need of
hell
she also said one need not be a chamber
to be haunted and also this an ear can
break a human heart as quickly as a
spear we wish the ear had not a heart so
dangerously near reading Emily Dickinson
will introduce you to a mind and a heart
that simply does not
require cue hearts it doesn't work like
mine but she knows yours and she knows
her own as well
thoughts like Dickinson's and like
Austin's can dislodge us from the
everyday world the things that we're
familiar with and the ways that we tend
to find it natural to think but isn't
that the value of an education and isn't
one of the most practical things that
that the world is seeking the world of
business the world of law world of
government the role of the arts even the
world of academia aren't they seeking
for people who take up new and strange
and different and creative perspectives
in other words isn't this take away from
these great and classic works may be
among the most practical things that
they have to offer us
my fourth value involved building your
muscles and your reading skills and the
ways that you're going to tackle
increasingly difficult material now I
don't think this one requires
illustration so much as it does a
reminder as we said you don't get to the
Olympics by training with weaklings and
these works have survived in part
because they've been written by geniuses
that is we know that these are mine's
worth wrestling with because so many
have the good news is that does not mean
that you have to be a genius to
understand them
thank God or I wouldn't have made it
very far myself you have heard the
saying she got to where she is by
standing on the shoulders of giants so
here are the Giants master the skills
that it takes to get up on their
shoulders and you're going to see quite
a distance you'll see more than they saw
you also be prepared better prepared to
grapple with lesser works that don't
stand is tall
so for the fifth value I said that to
the extent that you encounter engage
classic works successfully you'd be a
better judge of modern works and my
example here has to be Shakespeare now
many of the greatest critics and readers
of world literature including across
cultures and across boundaries have had
the same basic view of Shakespeare and
that is whatever is flaws
whatever the weaknesses and whatever the
strengths of other writers no one no
literary giant has ever written more
profoundly or more inventively or more
imaginatively about the human condition
than Shakespeare Harold Bloom the great
literary critic where I work and teach
here at Yale called one of his books on
Shakespeare the invention of the human
and he meant by this that Shakespeare
with these characters like Falstaff and
Hamlet and King Lear quite literally
created around the year 1600 our modern
sense of what it means to be a human
being acting and thinking in the world
many of his hundreds of memorable
characters men and women either vividly
or unexpectedly respond to their life
situations in ways that we couldn't
predict or typecast or they open up new
perspectives on what truly motivates
each of us so once you have successfully
engaged Shakespeare and is in his
comedies and in his tragedies you're
going to very quickly sense in other
writers whether or not they're capable
of doing the same thing and if they are
you're going to be drawn on to read them
and if they're not you can safely set
them aside because you've got a better
standard against which to make your
choices
let's say that you're persuaded of these
five valuable things that I say you can
take away from these work if you include
some of them on your course schedule in
college could your life be better
personally if you invited some of these
authors into it and how so so think
about it like this I shared an
experience a number of years ago when my
son got involved and I got involved as
well in the Boy Scouts we hiked we camp
we made friends but we had lots of
families and the troop lots of other
other adults on the trips it was all
fine it was wonderful but then we came
to a point in the development of these
young men and their skills where we were
prepared to introduce them to something
more adventurous and we planned a
two-week wilderness expedition something
that we hadn't come close to doing with
these young men before I was very
excited it was something that I had done
and I wanted my son to have the same
experience as I had had so let me get
this straight he said we'll have to
carry twice the weight on our backs that
we ever have before including the food
the food is going to be pretty bad we're
going to have to purify every single
drop of water we drink we'll have to
figure out our own trail it's going to
be in rugged mountains we'll probably
spend some time getting lost what
exactly am I going to get out of this
that I can't get from the hiking and
camping that we've already done which
I've like perfectly fine in which we did
without all this pain and hassle smart
boy
good questions so I thought we said you
know I don't think I can really tell you
what you're going to get out of this you
have to experience it for yourself and
then you'll know so I guess I'm just
asking you to trust me on this so my son
Paul certainly had some skeptical
company among the other Scouts in the
troop
and sure enough a few days into this
expedition things began to deteriorate
we had some lousy weather there's
blisters people were hungry
the boys are ragging on each other no
one's really getting along and my son is
looking at me with those all-knowing
eyes of a 16 year old but then the boys
started to toughen up the weather
queered we got higher up in the
mountains they started to rely on each
other more they figured out how to break
camp efficiently and so one day we get
to a really terrific climb during which
there was a fair amount of complaining
it was a brutal effort and when we
emerged from the from the treeline we're
on top of the highest peak in the region
we were exhilarated the boys were
exhilarated and my son came over to me
and he said hey dad I said what they
said this is fantastic I said I know he
said I just want you to know I get it
and I said what do you mean and he said
this is by far the most fantastic thing
that we've ever done together so what
had we learned by virtue of taking a
much more arduous much more difficult
journey than we had taken up to that
point in our scouting experience
well he's now got an experience of the
outdoors that's given him a permanent a
permanent interest that he can pursue in
life and of course there was also the
element of the experience that revolved
around the connection that he and I made
together by virtue of having the
experience together so remember what
Adler said in one sense of course the
great books are the most difficult to
read but they are in another sense the
most readable both for the less and the
more competent because they are the most
instructive and that's the key word
bird obviously I do not mean says Adler
most readable in the sense of with the
least effort even for the expert I mean
that these books reward every degree of
effort and ability to the maximum so
here's something else to think about and
it's something that Adler has to say and
it goes beyond the five takeaways that I
gave you four things that you things of
value that you can derive from these
books you're going to encounter a lot of
things in your life that you need to
know and things that you need to learn
about that aren't going to change you
much at all you've learned many of these
things already you learned how to drive
a car but that didn't change who you
were as a human being I'm suggesting to
you now that you're going to be in the
same position with relation to these
works we've been talking about in this
lecture as the scout who's done the
weekend hiking to take in the day trip
maybe cook breakfast at the camporee and
so forth remember how I said at the
beginning that Aristotle said it's our
nature to want to know things well just
as it's our nature to work to play to
find a mate to live in society remember
how I said that wisdom is something
different from knowledge well here's my
final thought for you and it's a deep
paradox of learning you don't
necessarily know what you are looking
for until you find it and it's the
effort of finding it that actually turns
you into a different person than the one
who set out on the journey to begin with
and that's why reading these great works
is very similar in fact to the
experience that my son had of a
wilderness expedition after never having
attempted anything more than what you
can get on the low lying ground so when
you finally do achieve a radical new
perspective when it's not just a matter
of taking in bits of in
information and knowledge but it's a
matter of changing how you put them
together and also it's a matter of
changing who you are as a result you
will see a different value in these
things and for instance these books and
you're also going to see yourself in a
new light so I give you the only answer
that I really can the best answer I know
why read these books it's the same
answer I gave my son you climb up into
the mountains you make your most
strenuous effort you give it everything
you have and what's your reward it's the
view it's the view thank you very much